back to the real ones in the castle
um welcome everyone um and good evening
this is the northwestern area planning
committee meeting today tuesday
25th of may 2021 my name is councilman
thompson and i'm the chairman of this
committee
welcome back everyone um in particular
welcome to councilman stevens who joins
us congratulations on your election
um this might feel slightly less
completely to you than the rest of us
but you know if you have any problems
just
let us know and we'll sort it out there
are just a few housekeeping issues to
run through
the setup of the meeting has been
designed to mitigate the coverage and we
asked members to
work to the protocol the grievance
council meeting on the 29th of april
2021 in the interest of member and
officer
safety we do have a limit of 17
persons whether offices members or
public in the chamber
and tonight there hasn't that been room
for one member who wishes to attend but
if we were full of other people
that wouldn't be possible
the meeting will be streamed live and
recorded and by being present in the
meeting you're giving your consent to
being recorded
members and officers during each item
please hope that you have to instead if
you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time uh the process this
evening will obviously be slightly
different
some items i may invite each member to
speaking so
therefore i encourage all members to
keep your contributions as clear and
concise
as possible please when invited to speak
please remain seated
remove your mask put on your visor and
speak clearly
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference
a page your paragraph number and keep
your contributions as clear and concise
as possible
write item two's apologies for absence
so thank you gentlemen
apologies been received from cancer
civil and council is white thank you
thank you
item three is the minutes of the 10th of
march uh it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 10th
of march
november 21 now on pages 7 to 12 our
approved is a true and accurate record i
have so much do i have a second one
cameras with darren very much uh
does everyone agree does anyone descent
does anyone have any matters of accuracy
i agree can we
[Music]
interest that's a member of essex county
council who are statutory council teams
in terms of uh
certain aspects of uh planning
applications thank you thank you
council family uh a non-pecunery as a
member of essex county
thank
application this evening that is the
barn at old mill house
we have the report we do have a public
speaker i think there's been a bit of
confusion about
when requests have to be submitted
because of the change that
i have
planning permission is sought for the
conversion of an existing agricultural
barn for dwelling house
for the vineyard manager at old mill
house vineyard
this application follows a previously
refused application for the same
proposal at the site
which was refused in may of last year
the previous application was refused on
the basis that
inadequate information had been received
to justify the essential need for
workers accommodation in this location
which would be outside of a defined
settlement in an unsustainable location
it was also considered that the
converted agricultural building to a
residential dwelling house
would have a detrimental impact on the
character and appearance of the
countryside
this is the location plan for the site
um the application sites area is
outlined in red
and it comprises two vineyards um as
well as the existing barn which is
located in the center of the site in the
favorite road
the blue line indicates the extent of
the land which is also in the
applicant's own ship
the application site is located within
the countryside out of any
defined settlement
this is the existing block plan for the
proposal
these are the existing elevations
these are the proposed elevations
these are the existing floor plans
this is the proposed ground floor fan
the
first floor plan which shows that four
bedrooms are proposed
and this is an aerial photograph
provided by the application applicant
these photographs are taken from hazel
hall lane
showing the existing barn and an access
point
from this accent access point which has
been created you can see the existing
house old mill house which is a listed
building
um which serves the whole site as you
saw in the block plan
and this is a picture of ultimate health
and this
is an existing property located opposite
the site access
these are photographs of the existing
farm
so um
to conclude the applications recommended
for refusal on the basis
that the applicants have provided
inadequate information to justify
the essential functional need for a
worker in this location
which is outside of the defined
settlement in the countryside
um
as explained in the committee report for
the application the proposal has been
assessed against policy h7 of the modern
local development plan policy h7 states
that permanent or temporary
accommodation in the countryside
where it relates to a rural enterprise
will only be permitted when a number of
criteria have been met
the criteria include evidence to be
submitted to the satisfaction of the
council
that there is a functional need for a
full-time worker in this location
in relation to a viable business there
are no suitable alternative dwellings
available
in the area to serve the identified
functional need
and the size of the proposed structure
is commensurate with the needs of the
enterprise concern
the development should also be designed
to minimize the adverse impact on the
character and appearance of the area
so as noted within the committee report
due to the evidence submitted
it has not been demonstrated that there
is an essential functional need for a
vineyard manager
at the site to reside on site on a
permanent basis
nor has it been demonstrated that the
four-bedroom dwelling house would be
commencement
commensurate to the needs of the
business concerned
no evidence has been submitted to
demonstrate that there are no other
suitable alternative dwellings available
in the wider area
or that the business is financially
viable with secure future
prospects the conversion of the barn to
a residential growing would also result
in the urbanization of the site
to the detriment of the countryside and
given that the proposed development
would result in the creation of a
dwelling
outside of a defined session of
boundaries in an unsustainable location
for all of the above reasons the
application is recommended for
refusal thank you thank you
all right we do have mr road to speak
could we get the timer
right so i'm going to invite the agent
mr roe to read out his submission
um can i remind you you've heard this
before
that i am very precise with my two
minutes i hate to be rude but
i also wouldn't like someone who cut out
10
important seconds to feel they've been
robbed because someone else had an extra
10.
um so please make so comfortable and
the time starts when you're ready thank
you good evening madam chairman and
members i'm stuart ray the agent for the
applicant richard britton richard has
firstly asked me to point out that the
parish council did respond
uh i'm not sure whether it reached you
or not but the council has apparently
agreed the vineyard provides a
beneficial addition to the village
contributing a further area of wine
growing to the region with potential
benefit for local employment
they recommended granting the
applications almost like staff who
manage the site efficiently i don't have
a copy of it but i'm told that's the
case
rich in 74 in his retired you set the
vineyard up because you thought it would
be fun to run one
um generating enough grapes for him to
sort of manage the site the process of
planting and nurturing and harvesting
and bottling and he thought would have
his own wine label
unfortunately all went rather swimmingly
and richard has become a victim of his
own success the yields from the fields
and the great quality have been very
high
um too high for him to manage the
process himself and so
he has had to appoint a farm manager
a vineyard manager specialist and
their whole process is now managed from
uh
as far as it were um the grapes are
grown harvested and transported to a
state-of-the-art bottle in plants at
bitmaker where they're sold and
incorporated into
existing established wine labels what
the consequence of that means is that
the barn which is
um relatively recent structure is
actually now redundant
the idea of a sort of hobby farm um
didn't materialize there are no real
appropriate alternative
uses for the farm uh in the context of
the surrounding vineyards so
the significant impediment to future
success concerns frost and having
someone on site a manager
particularly to deploy heaters in those
sort of frosty nights
is thought to be very important to the
future of the business richard is
to be frank too old to do himself his
list of buildings
uh uh not part of the agricultural
holding and so
he thinks conversion of the barn would
be appropriate so i hope that you're
able to support it this evening
before we move on with this there's a
couple of things i'd like to say
after some advice and training we've had
from planning advisory service
i'm not going to put the recommendation
to begin with
with debating the application not the
officers report um
another thing is could we possibly get
questions out of the way
first before we start to have a debate
or comment obviously questions may crop
up i'm not i'm not wishing to suppress
that in any way
and the other thing is we are no longer
referring to ward members in particular
since we are all here
for the district not for our boards
particularly
so that being said does anyone have any
questions for any of the officers
okay oh hang on sorry class of durham
your pen is hiding behind
it sorry chairman just can i just
clarify
whether this is the application is for
a dwelling pure dwelling or whether it
is for a dwelling with an agricultural
occupancy restriction please
the description of the application is
for the conversion of the agricultural
barn into vineyard manager's dwelling
house
so i assume that it would
be an agricultural occupancy
by the applications for that reason so
it has been assessed against that
okay thank you um council keys
um not quite with you what you said are
we look at the pictures now or
we're not debating it i don't really
know when you say i'm just giving an
opportunity for questions
before we debate but that by no means
rules out questions
before but if anyone has an item they'd
like to clarify then that's what
we go on could i clarify the entrance
place
is that by the bridge that i saw earlier
and that takes you to that
through them gates does that take you to
the house as well as the barn
which they'd like to convert into a
house um
and that is access shown on this
photograph takes you to the barn
there is a separate access which i show
you on
the map so there's another access point
here
right which i did have a photograph of i
just not into these
[Music]
but just for your information
um the access point and this access
drive
as well as all of the um
the periphery of the bond has not been
approved
in terms of um
so that exodus has been made
through making the hole in the hedge and
going up the field
okay thank you okay thank you um i do
have one question i noticed
um you know the officers feel there's an
insufficiency of
evidence um i wonder if you must under
or mr lee could explain
or clarify just what evidence you would
have been looking for
um yes of course so
as part of the application um the
applicants provided a planning statement
which they detailed the need for the
barn or their identified need for
the conversion of the barn to a dwelling
house and they stated that
the bar needed to be converted to a
dwelling house so
a member of staff could reside on site
at all times
due to frost was the main reason as well
as efficiency of the running of
the vineyard and security purposes so
we've obviously um in terms of the
policy we have to assess
whether there is a functional need for a
full-time worker to reside on site
on a permanent basis um and obviously
this is for a permanent conversion of a
building not a temporary permission for
a mobile home etc and as part of
the officers report so section 5.2
particularly 5.2.3
um where we've discussed the evidence of
the functional need for a full-time work
in this location
we have assessed the evidence submitted
um against equality and we are not of
the view that there is a
functional need in terms of the
arguments put forward
in terms of frost um frost only occurs
three times a year as per the evidence
submitted by the applicants
so the need for a vineyard
manager to reside on site to put out
fuji candles
when it is frosty or turn on wind
turbines we don't feel that there is a
functional need for the dwelling house
to be on site permanently all year round
for
three months of the year when there is
warning
that comes with frost obviously i
understand that
mr rowe stated that the applicant
is not um running the business
permanently himself they have extra
staff
but there is an existing dwelling house
less than 150 metres away from the site
um so we don't feel that there's an
additional need for a wedding house
in this location for those purposes
thank you thank you
[Music]
work out who you are
[Laughter]
i'm so very forgetful
sorry of course yeah i've just been on
it's just a question about the um
sort of business case because uh i can
see that last time
the application came through there was
criticism not in the sufficient business
case
uh and i i thought i wrote that the the
applicant has put a detailed business
case
with accounts you know submitted with
the application process saw some of
those
um i don't pretend to be an expert on
vineyards as to
uh as to whether it but it looked to me
like that was reasonable
are you suggesting that that isn't a
good business case
um is your question relating to the
viability of the business
okay um so yeah as part of the previous
application
i could see that i wasn't the case
officer for the for the application but
i could see that
um business report for expenditure of
reports
were submitted those were not submitted
as part of this
occupation um
however they also were not so
the previous business report showed
which i don't have on the
the report the presentation otherwise i
showed you
they showed that so that that was
submitted in 2020
and the reports showed that they had one
year of sales in 2019
and then 2020 2021 22
23 were all projected figures obviously
in cases such as this we would expect at
least a minimum of three to five years
business details of their financial
statements etc
so in terms of the business we feel that
it's in its infancy at the moment
um they haven't provided updated figures
so
from may of 2020 we haven't now received
as part of this current application
new updated figures for 2020
so we can't even see or assess the the
viability of the business for the last
two years at least
um in say in situations such as this we
might
allow um or permit a temporary caravan
or mobile home on site
yeah to allow the viability of the
business to
to be shown but obviously this
application is for a permanent combo of
an agricultural building for a dwelling
house so
without such information about the
viability of the business
we we can't tick that off in terms of i
see that it's a pity
that's not there if i may just the other
question um
i have just regarding um you mentioned
that no survey of other proxies had
been taken but that was pointed out in
the earlier application as well that
uh that seems a bit of a shortcoming too
then really though so
yeah we couldn't look at other
properties although i suppose it all
depends not being right
it all depends on how you know whether
something needs to be on site or not
what we really need as a counselor is a
line expert telescope
talk about flaming will jump in and
start debating
because that would be interesting to
know obviously we've all read the report
we've read the frosty weather issue i
mean i know possibly whether
it is very architectural just saying and
we all know that crosstalk kills
vineyards
a whole lot can go from my experience
with that with other
other crops so um i'd be very interested
to know
that point because it comes down to that
point of is it essential
is it essential to have something that
we all can see that it would be very
convenient
and it would be it might make common
sense i'm sure somebody has been there
and but on occasions uh obviously over
the last few years but
is it essential this is a balanced issue
and um it's difficult to grasp that and
assume that you're sort of vineyard
expert but unfortunately we might hear
something thank you
this is true um mr lee wanted to come
thank you chairman um just the clarity i
know ms duncan
did reference it but our policy is clear
that
you know when an underdevelopment of
business is relatively new
we do not grant permanent residential
accommodation
and as uh joshua explains you know we've
only got one year
threat of the evidence of financial
records so
our policy is quite clear that we
shouldn't be granting permanent
residential accommodation
in this instance it should be a
temporary permission to facilitate the
development because
if the business was to fall it's not
saying it will or it won't but if it was
default
then you would be stuck with a
residential property in a place where
you know we should only be granting
in exceptional circumstances and that's
why our policy allows for advocacy
wellness because it isn't exceptional
circumstances
but it does need to be in a business
where we are confident as an authority
that it will have a long time
and we'll have a life and you know
unfortunately this you know from what
the information we've got is it should
be two certainly according to our policy
to be granting terminal commission
could i just ask just on that very point
though um if
if um if there was a temporary
combination let's just say it was
character and something was there
and you were able to build up business
accounts for a few years
and then come come back with an
application and say look
would that in itself tip that box so to
speak would that be convincing
and if you've done a survey of the other
properties nearby ticking that box
which seems to be a short form of work
that would all be helpful for the
application
the chairman obviously that's exactly
what our policy requires so yeah so
no no yeah but so yeah so yeah so yeah
there is the
requirement that if they could recover
or overcome the other issues then
after evidence period then yeah we would
in theory support the terms
yeah thank you
okay uh council durham yeah thank you
chairman
well um to a certain extent chairman
here we go again don't we with
with our policies and we've all recently
had
um planning training um external
planning training and the importance of
adhering to our policies was um very
clearly spelt out to members
and i i do have sympathy with the
application um
with the applicant but unfortunately
this is ringing really horrible bells
for me
with a local example what we have here
is a fairly new barn in the middle of
nowhere in the middle of the countryside
um
that has now all of a sudden been
allegedly found to have no particular
use
and the full back position is for a
four-bedroom dwelling
and i recall unfortunately a very very
long saga in my
parish of a four-bedroom agricultural
dwelling
which was built on the pretext of having
forestry next to it that business failed
and
a four bedroom agricultural dwelling is
very difficult to justify
and it's very difficult to find another
person to use it
so i i am really gratefully concerned
and
and a a nice four bedroom dwelling it
would make
but i don't think it's justified for
an agricultural worker on the odd chance
that it may protect a vineyard from
frost and i'm afraid
at the moment and as mr lee has pointed
out we have insufficient evidence to
prove that
it is even necessary and i think that
if if things fall over in the next few
years what we're left with
is yet another large domestic dwelling
in an unsustainable location outside of
the village envelope and
we're just creating problems for
ourselves i would much rather see as
councillor jarvis has been alluding to
a temporary measure for two or three
years so that we can assess
whether this is actually required but i
i have very grave
reservations about granting this i'm
afraid
particularly given that this isn't an
old bomb that's having to be
preserved this is a brand new barn
and i'm certain that if the applicant
can put his mind to it i'm sure he could
think of other
uses for it other than a dwelling thank
you thank you
i have got you two but um council morley
was next then i've got council girls
thank you um i just really need is it
possible
to alternate uh alternate the across
automation i mean
do you need to be there full time after
the other thing
and i think we did you know on the
evidence we do need to see a bit more
evidence i think
thank you
thank you uh thank you chair um
possibly um our business experience is
relevant here i can say that
on our site we have only lost
crop once in 16 years
we are a different site there we have
we're closer to the coast
so we we get the air movement this site
is more inland
but yeah we've we sort of had a
catastrophic crop loss
only the once in 16 years just to help
you out
everybody on the committee but we are a
different site as i say we are
more closer to the river so we get
better airflow
um as an expert in the business
is one person enough one staff
to deal with however many acres of
findings
are you talking about for frost
prevention
measures yeah so is this where
everyone turns out does it wherever they
live yeah so it would be
more than uh one person but as i say
we'd we don't do it we don't
um it's a bit of a thankless task and it
i'm told it doesn't really work so you
just sort of have to
accept it thank you for that i haven't
crossed your
question list um but i need to go to
can't just
have some jarvis first then i'll come
home thank you that's so very
useful information there's a few other
points within the application
uh objectives building obviously we're
not putting that
a new building but there is a bar
and um you know we can't uh the the the
the situation is that uh african buildup
arm for a particular purpose
and business developed and the bomb is
no longer
needed for that purpose we shouldn't
really uh try and
determine whether that was prevalent or
anything like that's the situation is
what we've got in front of us the
situation in front of us if you've got a
redundant building
so i think my understanding of uh
the mppf is that uh is that that we
should look to
for the use of reuse redundant build i
think that's something
amongst a few things i've quite liked
obviously
i think with regards to
i know i know um obviously you're
familiar with uh
sections 82-84 of the nppo
and that does give uh exceptional
circumstances to
agricultural buildings in rural settings
with regards to being outside or
about because you know most rural
settings often are and there's some
special clauses there that
give them some extra
degree of flexibility regarding the use
of
a building outside of the planning
outside the north boundary area
if it's for agricultural purposes so i'd
quite like uh obviously to comment on
on that as well i think with regards to
the size of the property
you know i think if one was looking at
putting up a new property of course you
know you'd say well
that looks a bit big but it is what it
is isn't it you know there is a barn
there which is of a certain size
and of course it may not be one
individual
at some point it may be uh sorry
slightly distracted it may it may be but
it's a farm worker
who gets married and has a future i mean
i mean i think we shouldn't be
presumptuous we should apply a very
diverse policy we shouldn't assume
all farm workers are unmarried for
example so but i think the fact is
you've got a bar so you if you convert
it to a property it is the size that it
is
the fact that that ends up being a four
bedroom property
is just because that is the size of the
bar
and i quite like to know what's in these
views on that
it's got car parking space already
outside i know there's been
i don't think there's been much
reference to the garden but i think fuse
applications turned down
because of the garden size and
adjustments have been made and i think
the officers are satisfied with the
size of the garden which is being put
forward
so a lot has been said it often is
about properties uh causing an
urbanization effect
um causing harm to the countryside but
uh this
is a bomb that already exists um there
is very little
uh alteration uh out externally by
unlocking internal workforce
but i don't think it's substantially
going to look different i mean i've gone
to look at this farm i look at all the
applications
that i call it and i'm going to look at
it and i can see it's not
it's not seen by that that many other
properties
and it's set obviously in the middle of
the vineyards as we can see you can see
there's
not that much within sort of very review
of it uh within its
sight line so to speak so in terms of
harm to the countryside any
any property is a harmful countryside
the question of weight and debris
that's really question whether it's any
any substantial harm at all
to the countries because it's already
there and it's very um in keeping as
well which i believe is one of the
requirements
a building that is in keeping it's a
barn so it didn't keep
with the
part of the point about the urbanization
is if it's a dwelling that's necessarily
um domestic paraphernalia there will be
washing lines and garden sheds and
potentially wendy houses and all sorts
so
nobody lives in just the house um mr lee
you might wish to answer that or would
they come and protect it
thank you chairman i won't quite answer
it in the way that
council is stating questions i think
maybe slightly a different approach
government guidance is clear that
dwellings in rural areas should only be
allowed in exceptional circumstances and
one of those is
agriculture dwellings when they are
needed to
support the uh commercial enterprise
business and um but the mppf is also
clear that the starting point for any
application is the development plan on
this material situations indicate
otherwise and our policy
h7 supports the mppf in relation to
providing residential dwelling from the
countryside
through agriculture dwellings and it
provides the criteria
that the council should look at when
supporting these
and the fact is that officer faulk shows
their number of points they haven't
evidenced
and secondly our policy is clear that we
shouldn't be supporting
a embryonic business in a provision of a
permanent dwelling
so this policy and the mppf go hand in
glove together the mppf is just the ball
of guidance and this is the specifics
that we should be looking at
so this is further detailed than the
mppf but that's
our local plan that's the starting point
of our determination of any application
and the second um yeah um there's two
things one the policy requires that
the property should be um
to meet the need of the business um
it isn't about an aspirational property
is about the need
and we're not saying that it will be
assumed that
the aircraft worker is going to be
single but on the flip side we shouldn't
be assuming that it will be someone with
a large family
and as the council durham said you know
larger the property is more difficult it
would be
to retain that as an agriculture
dwelling in the long term if the
business was to foul and
you know we've had numerous applications
since i've been here
um at this committee and south east 50
million central if any
removing um agriculture workers
dwellings on the base is that because
they're so large they're actually
unviable to be
meeting the needs of an agricultural
worker so you know
we've got that evidence that we've had
those problems before so i think
that's quite an important criteria for
the policy and members should be aware
of that
and as you said german you know just
because the building is there
there is intensification car parking of
paraphernalia
i do think council jarvis's point about
basically there's a barn there it won't
cause an additional heart
it's a very dangerous statement for the
committee to any member of the committee
to make because
you know people here and use arguments
for that against us and that is
basically saying that any agricultural
building in the
district would could be turned into a
dwelling and that's a lot of dwellings
through the
countryside if we were to do that on
such a full brush approach to
determination of plan applications
thank you uh counselors who haven't had
their first goal yet
so i have in order council fleming
councillor keith and council steve
so how's the family please oh no
actually
oh right you've done it okay thank you
um
thank you
i understand about agricultural
exceptions
um but i don't see that they're to do
with convenience
and i don't see that black lens the fact
that it's agricultural then special
weight
to convenience lots of businesses need
people on site
at funny hours of the day and night and
both staff are on call
and they just have to come in when
they're called and they don't live on
site
if you're an i.t technician you don't
live on site and that's just how it is
thank you thank you
okay council keys then we'll go back to
council but i'll
come back wearing a couple of hats in
mine or council seals of my ward
we have just lost an appeal for a
concrete road with a hole made for a
hedge
i know it was going for a farm this is
done for the final present
so and i'm also with my driving
hat on new accesses big accesses for
mild
moving agricultural machinery and laura
is about which i will
go obviously to move the grapes away
from the vineyard
and i do commend the chat because there
is a heck of an
expense on building a vineyard with all
if we could go back to the
pictures please of all the metal work
for the vines to hang over
this is not something i think he's put
up
willy-nilly it's not a case of running a
tractor around with a drill putting in
some seed
there is a heck of a financial costs so
i cannot see him
wanting to take it away too quickly
also frost twice a year i was snowed in
in great shots and last year
for three days only like a gallon
four-wheel drive so yeah i don't
think that's probably ghosts there is
more than one frost
and there's a barn there already yes
it's the size it is councillor jarvis
has said that
no really any more so i don't
but i do commend him for the expenses
done to do that and especially in this
climate
i think um i would just say i think
we're talking about the same but
it did eventually succeeded appeal
because
extra evidence of name was produced at
that appeal
um having lost two appeals
i still wanted to film do you german
there's nothing in this application the
reason computer about the access
or anything anyway so it's not part of
consideration this application
so i think it's a new point thanks um
if we have the evidence we would
probably have granted it but it was
produced
um sorry council fleming does
thank support chairman i just wanted to
clarify for councillor keith's
um benefit it's it's frost at a
particular time of year that's dangerous
so it's frost when the buds have burst
so it
so it can be very dangerous in may for
example you've had
you've had warm weather the buds burst
and then there's a frost and then it
kills the whole crop
so it's it's
well it doesn't often happen we haven't
experienced it
we've only experienced it once but as i
say we're a different site
thank you uh right i think we've been
around everyone's
let's go for councillor no chairman i
just wanted to come back to this this
four bedroom issue because that was
exactly the issue
with the property in wooden walter and
uh the the applicant kept coming back
time and time and time again saying
um because it was a four bedroom
dwelling and it had an agricultural
restriction they couldn't find an
agricultural worker
that it suited and that was their
reasoning for getting the agricultural
tie lifted as i said that application
came here
numerous times went to appeal and they
lost on appeal
because the um the planning
uh inspector did say that um
it was out of scale with the
requirements for an agricultural workers
dwelling
so um i accept the fact that that that
building is
is there um but i i just am slightly
concerned about it and i will remain
safe thank you
mr lee right so just to back up cancer
stone's point um we have won a hearing
about nicole dwelling where
they wanted to put a doorman in to put a
room in the room nobody had one and they
wanted an extra bedroom
you know there is a policy it has
requirements and inspectors do stand by
and i would be very worried if members
would just
discount those requirements of the
policy um
i've said many committees you know but
if we do ignore the requirements we are
walking down the policies and we are out
undermine our ability to defend
ourselves against the
development that is against the ldp
thank you
absolutely thank you um yes my team
is that you know i don't object to this
on any kind of principle
but we have policies and i
don't see why applicants can't fulfill
the requirements of the policies we've
had without
advertising commercial properties
they're not advertised and you know men
say well nobody's going to want that are
they that's not
the point we have a requirement
we are opening floodgates to all sorts
of things that we can't then stop
when even when they're incredibly
inappropriate
because we haven't followed our own
policies so
that said i'm going to put the officer's
recommendation to refuse do i have a
second
can we have shell pads please those in
favor of the officer's recommendations
and reviews
uh that means there aren't any
extensions so that's the place for the
guests
so in fact that application is
refused for the reasons given in the
office's report
and that actually brings us to the code
of the meeting i thank everyone for
their time
for their efforts they're making to
cooperate with the protocols
and i'm going to ask you to leave
through that door
and could you please file yourselves out
so we're not bumping into each other